[Music]
[Applause]
all right
mark few the gonzaga head coach they're
26-0 they beat byu
on tuesday night to win the wcc title
coach good morning how are you today
uh all is well dan good morning to you
uh voice is a little shaky but other
than that
well that's that's your your mid-season
points your coaching voice right
yeah you know what it's weird it's
always bad in november and then it kind
of
i don't know callus is over and then uh
man seems like in march it
bites me again so i don't know how many
times have you been tested this year
i would say 100 to 125
or something like that would be my guess
yeah
my nostrils have had enough they are
they are
ready to go on strike have you been
vaccinated
uh i have actually yes and what about
your team
no no because i don't know if you heard
what happened with duke they had a
player
tested positive and it looks like their
season's over
uh i did hear i just heard that
it's it's uh gosh that's what we all
fear and uh
you know the tough thing is and this is
the frustrating thing dan
is you know we're all doing
all our protocols and sitting away from
each other and spacing and meetings and
literally everything we've been doing
all year and it's tough especially when
one player tests positive that the whole
group goes out i don't know i don't know
the particulars in that it's handled
differently in every county
um and in tournaments and such but uh
yeah that i mean that's that's our worst
nightmare this year i mean
that's you you play in bed just waiting
to get the text from the trainer that
everybody's
okay on you know passing their tests
will you use this as a cautionary tale
to your team today
no we've been really really cautionary
already man i mean we are
i actually uh took them out of their
living arrangements who are relatively
pretty darn safe by most uh
standards and we put them in a hotel and
uh prior to the wcc tournament and when
we got back late uh tuesday night they
were back in the hotel and we got our
our practice facility shut down and and
uh i mean we're already
doing everything that we possibly can um
does it feel like it's been a year since
we shut down the sport
man in some ways it feels like five
years and then uh
um yeah yeah i mean it feels like it's
been at least a year
quite frankly i mean this is it's been a
i it's been a really really interesting
challenging um but also
uh i i mean i couldn't have picked a
better squad to go through such a crazy
year with their their enthusiasm and
their energy has been contagious
uh all year and the way they just handle
this thing
all the stuff that's going on uh they've
handled it with a lot of grace
and i think just collectively across the
landscape of college basketball that
everybody has and just shows the just
how bad everybody wants to play and
and uh you know how important the sport
is to all of us and even
to our country yeah don't use the word
contagious coach that's not a
yeah yeah good call yeah don't
don't don't do that overwhelming or
something like that but that uh
that makes some people uh nervous
um are is gonzaga still a mid-major when
it comes to basketball
come on you know the answer i know but
my job is to ask the question coach
yeah he's not not an intelligent guy
like you that's like a
a cub beat reporter would ask that
so i hold you in such higher esteem than
that
okay coach
you answer this we're coming up on our
fifth straight number or fifth straight
number one seed in the
i don't know in the last seven years or
something where we went to five straight
sweet 16s at least
yeah you know and i don't know that
anybody's done that in recent
history that's at least within the lead
eight in the national championship game
so uh you know i mean it speaks for
itself so
i i the re i i was kind of mocking the
mid major label with gonzaga because
that didn't translate as well as i
thought it was going to coach
and your sarcasm usually does that
you know and i'm a sarcastic guy that's
why i love your sarcasm
okay so you guys are you're you're not
that plucky mid-major anymore
not cute and fuzzy you're you're a
dominating college basketball power
well i'll tell you this let's do this
for the next three you know
week and then who knows what happens
let's treat us as a plucky little
okay you know the little cinderella and
let's
you know the expectations will be low
and why wonder about that coach we
got started if we can keep the score
close it'll be uh
it'll be a win-win for everybody right
but be careful what you ask for a lot of
times coaches or players will go
nobody uh took us you know seriously or
you know we didn't get any credit or any
of those things there
as long as you know and your kids know
hey let's just play if we you know get
recognition great if we don't
the final recognition is when we win we
win the championship
but not everybody subscribes to that
though coach a lot of people are like oh
you know you didn't take us
you know like that for you you took us
for granted
yeah certainly after all the attention
that's been on us
actually going all the way back to uh
october you know or even in the the
preseason stuff started coming out in
the summer uh
you know you know what's really kind of
interesting i don't know who's been
able to stay number one all the way
from basically july until into march
you know it's been a it's been a quite a
run uh uh that way with this squad and
and
again back to kind of what i said
earlier they're just an amazing group
that doesn't seem to be
rattled by anything and they're they're
having
just a lot of fun playing together and
that might sound corny but i'm just
telling you it's real
and you know the undefeated thing was
not
even an issue at all and i mean we
finally addressed it after the game the
other night just because
i think it's important to understand
it's just a heck of an accomplishment
right and then
and they feel good about it but it's not
something that they're
thinking about or dwelling on uh you
know i think we're they're just
all of them have been you know what you
talked about earlier
you know a portion of my team missed out
on this last year
you know we were going into it as a
number one seed and get a host in
spokane and so
they're just dying to get back and play
in the ncaa tournament that
new guys that we have in the program
came to gonzaga
because they wanted to play in the ncaa
tournament and have a chance to win a
championship and so uh
they're all excited to just you know get
back there and go for it
when you recruit i know suggs is
probably a one and done
um but are you rec did you recruit him
knowing he was a one and
how often do you recruit somebody you
think like collins
uh was one and done but are you do you
recruit
the one and donors or is it just if they
show up and they're better than
what we think or they get that
recognition that then they become a
one-and-done
yeah i mean in zack's case he really i
mean he
just came on like gangbusters especially
at the end of the of the year
and you know played so well in the in
the ncaa tournament that it ended up
you know being kind of a no-brainer type
decision
uh look we we go out we recruit the guys
that we think would be great at gonzaga
um if that ends up being somebody that's
gonna stay in school for one year or
three years or four years
we don't limit it but i mean we're
pretty particular about who we recruit
as far as
you know what what do they value do they
value you know winning
first and and you know the
gonzaga and the ant and and
and their college career even if it's a
short one or are they here to just
post numbers and get to the league that
doesn't really work uh
at our place uh so in jalen's case i
mean
i just fell in love with his competitive
spirit and
and just his feel for the game and how
he impacted the game everywhere and then
as we dove deeper into it i mean he he
uh uh was so into development and really
wanted to to grow his game and get his
ball screen reads down
and you know grow on the defensive side
of the ball also
and so once you met the family and all
that is it was like it was a
you know definitely all the
characteristics and attributes that
we're looking for
i saw where you uh would give a pep talk
or wish somebody a happy birthday
uh this was on uh cameo the cameo app
yeah yeah you saw that huh yeah
okay i know yeah i don't know so wait so
what do i get if i
would would you like me to do that for
you or anything or uh yeah like if i
pony up 200
on cameo like what am i getting and your
voice
your voice is shot like i'm not even
getting it true pep talk there
i know it's uh yeah
uh i don't know i don't do a whole lot i
haven't done those for a while
we were trying i was trying to help the
athletic department and raise some money
uh
since we're uh all of us athletic
departments are
down this year with no fans and and uh
games being impacted and things like
that but uh
yeah it's kind of a fun thing to do and
some people seem to enjoy it
well i will make sure that the country
does not make that mistake
that you're you're not a mid major
you're a juggernaut
you're dominating you're on that you're
on the same level as
duke and north carolina and kentucky and
all of those teams
although not this year
well we haven't we have not accomplished
what those
programs have over the 100 years of the
college basketball but uh oh don't down
play get a great run
yeah come on don't downplay it let's go
you're the team to beat you're you're
calling out everybody that's the way we
got to go into this coach
well you know what we're going into this
favoring uh
every moment we got and starting with
the first one and we're going to
celebrate every moment we got
so uh you should hopefully it's going to
be an interesting ride though dan i mean
it's this this
uh whatever the hell we're calling a
controlled environment in india there's
going to be
a lot more to how you handle that uh
as as well as playing in the games
because that's going to be a really
really long
slog in a hotel uh
for any of these teams that you know
advance all the way to the final four
into the national championship
are you going to show your team hoosiers
before
you leave town that's a great question i
mean that
you know we might just do that today i
was kind of racking my brain for
something to do uh
uh today you know you know you'll be
weird is how probably
none of them have even seen it that just
kind of ages you and i just
i know you know what i can do coach is i
have
a basketball hoop here i'd be willing to
shoot some hoops here and like
let your kids see something truly
inspirational
that even at my age i'm still an elite
shooter
and if i can help you in any way
leading our zags to the national title
if you want me to give a peck talk since
you can't do it with your voice
free of charge no cameo well you know
it's interesting you say that because i
don't get that same vibe from your
production team there
they they act like you're not the number
one rated prospect of the group
on the hoop oh wow but you know what
they do coach
they keep me humble look what they say
i'm not there every day
they keep me humble coach that's what
they do
right that's the job of you know great
coach great team
keep the star humble absolutely
so and hungry hungry and humble uh
good luck coach always great to talk to
you and uh congrats on the undefeated
season so far
you got it dan thanks fun thank you
coach that's mark few gonzaga head coach